[Music]
paulo i'm curious
when you were first considering whether
or not to join metrostar in your current
role
did the company's openness to
technologies like the pi data stack and
open source scientific computing in
general
did that make a difference to you it
absolutely made the difference
it was really important to me to find a
company that was gonna let me
experiment and like have an open uh i
guess like
open range to figure out like which
tools and solutions were going to work
best it was important to me if they
weren't going to lock me into using this
or that
licensed product or a piece of software
and
it served us well it's helped us stay
dynamic uh adaptable paulo do you feel
like the
well-supported ecosystem of open source
scientific computing tools such as the
ones that we use in the pi data stack do
you feel like that has accelerated your
ability to deliver
real results at your company without
question
yeah i would absolutely say that it has
um
the fact that i can uh you know like
google around for like some solutions
i can check the forums i can you know
check
conda kind of forge install things find
the tutorials
uh get the documentation um all of those
things
are incredible accelerators
um i don't i think one of the
most important lessons i've learned
about coding in general is that
it's not always about how smart you may
be
it's about how many smart ideas you've
been exposed to
so having that exposure and that ability
to see
all these brilliant solutions that are
in the open source community is
an invaluable resource so what are you
most excited about
personally about the upcoming pie data
global event
i'm excited to learn a bunch of cool
stuff that i haven't learned before
i'm excited to see uh new projects new
ways of thinking about data and python
i'm excited to see what the community
looks like at a global scale
and yeah i'm just excited to participate
in like such a fantastic community
[Music]
you